baldwin not taking any responsibility
for the death of cinematographer helena
hutchins after accidentally shooting her
on a movie set baldwin continues to
insist he didn't even pull the trigger
and is even pinning blame on the victim
everything is in her direction
she's guiding me through how she wants
me to
hold the gun for this angle there are
some who say you're never supposed to
point a gun
at anyone on a set no matter what
unless the person is the cinematographer
who's directing me where to point the
gun for her camera angle i cocked the
gun can you see that can you see that
can you see that and she says and then i
let go of the hammer of the gun and the
gun goes off do you feel guilt
no no
i feel that there is i i feel that that
that
someone is responsible
for what happened and i can't say who
that is but i know it's not me
i hated everything about that interview
degan and i one of the things i really
dislike about it is that we you know
i'll just speak for myself but i felt
very empathetic towards him and defended
him and thought wow this is so terrible
and then to watch him a month later
basically disassemble everything that we
witness with our own eyes and that we
knew and trying to convince us
that he has nothing to do with it
is pitiful he tried to act like the
victim alec baldwin is not the victim
and he clearly didn't do that interview
to make elena hutchins family feel
better he did it to burnish his
reputation and put a shine on his image
maybe get ahead of the future legal
wrangling over her death
i didn't think he could possibly come
across like a bigger narcissist
or a bigger ego maniacal monster
the man who called his daughter a pig
when she was young on a voicemail
message uh the rage machine but somehow
he did but
hollywood is watching this reading the
comments on social media about is very
telling he is a festering boil on the
neck of hollywood and he will be lanced
at some point figuratively in the very
near future i don't see how he has a
career after this he indicated that
jessica he basically said well maybe my
career is over but you know he's at the
same time blaming the cinematographer
who was the very woman who got shot and
died and at the same time said that when
she saw when he saw
her husband that they embraced and
talked about how they're both going
through something and he made sure to
say well what you're going through is
worse yeah yes yeah you lost your wife
and your son has no child has no mother
anymore
i found it all very strange we talked
yesterday about doing this as a dramatic
interview was a mistake because it
undoes any of the emotions that we
thought that he was having after the
event you know he just put out a very
short twitter statement a couple of days
later that just said absolutely in shock
destroyed over this and he's clearly
courting public opinion now because he
said in the interview that he's been
assured that he's not going to be
charged with anything
no one is going to like that interview i
doubt if he watched it back he would
even like that interview and i don't
know if he just got ahead of a ahead of
his ski out over his skis whatever the
saying is and just went with it because
he was feeling
powerful at that moment because he was
back on tv and he was being interviewed
by someone powerful but it does not read
well so i don't know about that that
nobody will like the interview i was
listening to npr this morning jesse uh
before i came to work and it was 5 45 in
the morning in case anyone's checked and
there's a reporter
telling
his audience
what happened on the interview and at
the end he tells the host
i believe this was a master class
in how to answer a lot of questions to
protect yourself but not to advance a
story i mean it was basically like
saying what a great job alec baldwin did
i'm getting texts from family members
not my mother conservative family
members who think that alec was the real
deal he was genuinely upset
and
i i don't see it that way i see him
acting as a lawyer instead of a human
being he probably should have just cried
for an hour and said i'm sorry for an
hour instead of getting up there like he
was testifying under cross it made no
sense a few times when he said well i
never checked the gun to see if it's hot
and then he says he stays up at night
because he can't sleep he's always
thinking about what he could have done
differently well he could have checked
the gun because that's what clooney said
clooney came out and said you know we
always check the gun to see if it's hot
and stephanopoulos hit him with the
clooney line and go oh good for him good
for him that was not the right thing to
say and then to say he acted like he
never heard anything was wrong on the
set people were walking off because
there was an accidental discharge people
were walking off because of bad
conditions we have this part of the
interview this is this is
quite unbelievable what he said happened
immediately afterwards
she goes down
i thought to myself
did she faint
the notion that there was a live round
in that gun
did not dawn on me till probably 45
minutes to an hour later
i mean that's obviously checkable yes
but also i mean we're as we're listening
to this we're going like what the hell
who made the decision about the music
as if it that music is necessary to tell
this story and it tells you the obvious
thing that this isn't journalism it's
choreography it's been a month right 30
days that's not journalism he came this
has been fabricated or
manufactured with the help of abc and
george stephanopoulos uh the music uh
the tension everything there is designed
to help him out uh the argument itself
if it actually
you know it takes hold in the public
consciousness
how many people are gonna use this like
the gun went off the gun went off the
gun went off and everybody knows that's
impossible it's impossible if this could
have been you know i hate to use the
phrase a teachable moment on gun safety
instead it's like completely the
opposite this is like it's like
i just point i didn't point i pointed
the gun and it just went off it's just
like this isn't possible it's impossible
but that's baldwin's defense and if it
actually becomes commonplace then you're
gonna you will see more and more and
more again i go back to i've said this a
million times
if they hadn't demonized the nra
the nri nra could have been
on these sets you can't i mean you could
have benefited from the instruction and
the supervision but instead you
demonized a group
that probably could have saved that
person's life but instead it's just more
important to be politically correct than
it is to be safe you're right about
we'll see if anybody comes up with the
alec baldwin defense yes it will be
coming i add though to your point
maureen callahan in the new york post
today she was interviewing a gun safety
expert from the movies and said why
didn't and raise the issue of why didn't
george stephanopoulos just simply ask
him
if you had to put that gun to your head
would you have checked it mm-hmm oh
that's a good question oh
but again
but this was a it was a layup and it was
it was a show just like his wife and the
his fake spanish wife
and the show they put on in vermont
after well he killed the dp on his film
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else